now another thing that might be weighing
on Biden is his family's legal exposure
during yesterday's Senate hearing
Biden's hatchet man at the Department of
Justice mayor Garland swore he's going
to remain hands off on the investigation
promised to leave the matter of Hunter
Biden in the hands of the U.S attorney
for the District of Delaware Who was
appointed in the previous administration
a pledged not to interfere U.S attorney
in Delaware has been advised that he has
full authority to make those kind of uh
referrals that you're talking about or
to bring cases in other jurisdictions if
he feels it's necessary but former FBI
assistant director and frequent angle
guest Chris swecker he's not buying it
Eric Garland knows what he's supposed to
do he's the surrogate for the for the
administration it's just a wink and a
nod I I don't you know he can pledge
that he won't interfere all he wants but
there is no reason why the U.S attorney
in Delaware should be sitting on this
case for well over a year
what is taking so long joining me now is
Kentucky Congressman James Comer chair
of the house oversight committee Mr
chairman do you agree
that there's something fishy going on
with this elongated timeline
there's something very fishy there's no
better example of a two-tier system of
justice in America than what we see
happening with Hunter Biden I mean he's
owed two million dollars in back taxes
for years and years yet nothing was done
about it he has charges he has probably
more Bank violations than any uh
American that that I've ever seen and I
come from a pretty decent banking
background this guy if you look at what
Stephen Miller released today with the
documents that he obtained through a
four-year request you could make a very
easy argument that Hunter Biden was an
unregistered foreign agent that's a very
serious crime I mean and the list goes
on and on money laundering and even
worse but yet nothing has been done and
we haven't even heard a peep from this
Delaware U.S attorney it's very odd
everyone in America is keeping up with
this case yet Merrick Garland continues
to act like well he doesn't know
anything about it he's staying out of it
I don't think anybody believes that no
and of course Mr chairman the New York
Times is backing the doj's handling of
the probe by about Hunter Biden and
saying that Joe Biden should clearly
call for his son to cooperate but not
with the Republican circus on the hill
but with the justice department that
would let Hunter Biden stand on his own
and allow the administration to focus on
issues that matter most to the American
people
so Congressman clearly they're worried
that you all might actually uncover
something and frankly just State what's
on the record
in a persuasive manner not that the
media will cover it but we will
look at how the mainstream media has
changed just in the last six weeks just
since we've taken over and I've become
chairman of the house oversight
committee and Jordan's become chairman
Judiciary Committee the media has gone
from all of this was just a Witch Hunt
it was Russian disinformation to now
okay yeah there's probably some wrong
doing there but we don't need to put the
Biden family through all this with the
Republican circus we need to let the
Merrick Garland do the right thing we
trust Merrick Garland and and he'll
he'll do the right thing so the media
has done a complete 180 on this already
everyone realizes the evidence is out
there they what they has really scared
of Laura is the fact that just this week
we've spoken with four people that were
involved in the Biden family influence
peddling schemes they're coming forward
now they're starting to cooperate our
attorneys are working with their
attorneys so we're making progress with
this investigation oh well just the way
they treated president Trump at
Mar-A-Lago with the way they held back
the info information of the search of in
the finding of these classified
documents at the Biden residence and the
slow role of all that information I mean
just that tells us what this FBI and
justice department is all about this is
political bias ingrained in our legal
system now and and they're supposed to
be the Defenders of democracy really
yeah no and you look at what the general
counsel for the National Archives
admitted in a transcribed interview with
us was that he wasn't allowed to post
things on the National Archives website
about the Biden mishandling classified
documents and he wasn't allowed to
respond to me because the doj or the
White House one he wouldn't admit but it
was one of the two blocked him but he
could do whatever he wanted on the Trump
mishandling of classified documents
another example of a two-tier system of
justice run by Merrick Garland now the
lawyer one of the lead lawyers or top
defense lawyer quit Hunter Biden's legal
team
what does that say about the state of
this case
it says a lot you know I want to hope
that that lawyer saw so much evidence of
someone that was abusing his power
abusing his family's name at the expense
of American National Security and he
walked away or it could be because the
new lawyer on the team Abby Lowell is
doing some things that I think are
getting real close to crossing the line
so you know either way this is a sign of
disarray in the Biden camp and I think
you're going to see more spin coming out
of the White House and more calls for
either a special counsel or first for
some way for Merrick Garland to come in
and save the day and block us from our
oversight well Hunter Biden better do a
lot more of that blow art if he's going
to pay those bills Congressman thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else